what was once a distant memory is now a
reality u.s inflation rates are at a
level not seen since the early 1980s in
a poll released friday 40 percent of
americans listed inflation as one of
their top priorities for the government
to address in the coming year but the
u.s is not alone rates are climbing
globally and in britain inflation has
reached
9.1 percent
roxanna saberi has been talking with
londoners who are struggling with
soaring prices
deep fried
and deeply loved feels like a treat
would have it what's long been britain's
national dish is now taking a battering
perfect storm across rises it's a
difficult one to manage at kennedy's
fish and chip shop in london richard
pickering says fallout from brexit the
pandemic and now the war in ukraine have
cranked costs up 25 to 30 percent
from the cod to the flower for the fish
the potatoes even the sunflower oil for
frying most of it comes from either
russian steps or ukraine and that supply
is just not available at the moment the
industry says the price pressure has
already forced dozens of the uk's
roughly 10 000 fish and chip shops to
shut down and warns thousands more are
at risk customers here tell us they
notice the effects of inflation on their
plates and beyond generally speaking
the price of meals has gone up and you
probably noticed that as well a cost i
would say i've turned the heating off
and i'm cold sometimes
so i put a
blanket round or a cardigan on rather
than put the heating on and i'm
yes and i'm
uk's inflation rate has spiked to over
nine percent for the first time in four
decades that's even higher than
americans are seeing
so
basically
inflation isn't just a u.s thing
it is absolutely not a u.s thing
stephanie flanders is a bloomberg
economist and journalist in the uk we
are so dependent on these imports from
the rest of the world be it energy be it
food and it's precisely those things
that are going up in price
why should americans care should they
care you know it can have ripple effects
in the u.s it can add to a volatile
global environment
wages in the uk have lagged behind
protesters have called on the government
for more help
how were we expected to put food on the
table to have a shelter over our heads
and some food banks are struggling to
stay stocked londoners like charles
dalson are turning to their own green
thumbs
he says he saves at least 120 dollars a
month eating vegetables he grows on this
plot which he rents from his
neighborhood council
how does the price of these compared to
what you'd find in the store
these are cheaper they taste better
as food prices have surged so has demand
for spots like this across the country
the average waiting list is several
years long people are starting to
realize how much how important
being able to grow their own food is and
they can reduce their family budget by
doing so it all adds up and it's a big
help back at kennedy's pickering hopes
britain's fish and chip shops weather
this storm it survives and flight in two
world wars it's going to be difficult
and there will be some casualties
eventually he says the crowds will come
back for more
for cbs saturday morning
roxanna seberry london
dozens of fish and chip shops that just
seemed shocking to know and it's so
difficult because how much more can you
raise prices on the menus for those
customers before they turn away to it it
is a true ripple effect that you're
seeing the only the only silver lining
is that the dollar is is you know pretty
well juxtaposed against the euro but
i'll be there next week and i'm just
bracing myself for those added costs i'm
curious to hear from you what it because
it's so different when you actually see
the bill we've all said it like you go
to the grocery store and then you're
like what so once you do that to see
what those are like